tenemos esta función g x igual a x
cuadrada más 5 x menos 14 dividido entre
x cuadrada más 4 x menos 21 y nos dice
el ejercicio que para cada uno de los
siguientes valores de x selecciona sí
que tiene un cero una cinta vertical o
una discontinuidad removible y aquí nos
dan nuestras tres opciones para los
valores de x del cual hay que determinar
si es cero jacinto está vertical o
discontinuidad removible así que como
siempre te invito a que hagas una pausa
trates de resolverlo por tu propia
cuenta pero bueno ahora vamos a
resolverlo nosotros juntos y antes de
fijarnos realmente en las opciones que
tenemos lo que quiero hacer es
factorizar el numerador y el denominador
para poder ver cuándo es que el
numerador y el denominador se anulan muy
bien entonces vamos a tratar de
factorizar esto aquí por ejemplo
necesitamos dos números que
multiplicados nos den menos 14 y sumados
más 5 eso
- sería x 7 verdad que multiplica a x2
entonces 7 x menos 2 nos da menos 14 y 7
al sumarle menos 2 nos da 5 entonces
aquí tenemos bien la factorización y
ahora en el denominador vamos a buscar
dos números que multiplicados nos den
menos 21 pero que sumados nos den 4
entonces aquí nuevamente podríamos tomar
x + 7 y tendríamos que tomar x menos 3
verdad entonces 7 x menos 3 es menos 21
y 7 menos 3 es 4 muy bien entonces
pensemos ahora cuando es que el
numerador se anula entonces pensemos
aquí que el numerador voy a ponerlo así
el numerador será igual a 0
y x es igual a menos 7 verdad y así es
que así se anularía este factor o bien x
es igual a 2 verdad para qué entonces se
anule este segundo factor ahora pensar
en pensemos qué ocurre con el
denominador entonces el denominador será
igual a 0 si x es igual a menos 7 y así
este factor se anularía o bien si se
anula el otro factor para lo cual
necesitaríamos que x sea igual a 3
verdad entonces como podemos ver aquí
tenemos nuestros tres candidatos para
los valores interesantes de x verdad
pero lo que podemos notar es que cuando
x no es menos 7 estos dos factores se
pueden cancelar verdad y entonces la
expresión digamos más simplificada que
tenemos de esto de aquí sería x menos 2
dividido entre x menos 3 verdad sólo que
tenemos que agregar una restricción
x no puede ser menos 7 y entonces esto
hay que agregar lo porque si fuera menos
7 en la expresión de la izquierda
tendríamos 0 entre 0 y eso no está
definido verdad entonces hay que agregar
esta restricción para que estas dos
expresiones sean algebraica mente
equivalentes entonces aquí tenemos algo
interesante verdad porque antes teníamos
que cuando x era igual a menos 7
tendríamos una expresión de la forma 0
entre 0 pero justamente pudimos
removerlo y si lo graficar amos verdad
si gráfica vamos esta función lo que
tendríamos sería una una curva digamos
continua que tiene un agujero verdad
tiene un agujero es decir tiene un punto
en donde no está definida justo en x
igual a menos 7 y en general cuando
tenemos la situación en donde tenemos un
factor que aparece tanto en el numerador
como en el denominador y que además
aparezca con el mismo exponente por
ejemplo aquí en este caso el exponente
es uno verdad entonces tendremos una
discontinuidad removible entonces
justamente aquí en -7 tenemos una
discontinuidad removible ahora vamos a
ver qué es lo que ocurre con las otras
opciones veamos aquí podemos determinar
que en x igual a 2 tenemos un 0 verdad
porque justamente es cuando se anulan
nuestro numerador y no se anula el
denominador verdad entonces aquí en x
igualados tendremos un 0 y en cambio en
x igual a 3 verdad sería cuando se anula
el denominador pero el numerador no se
anula verdad entonces en este caso
tenemos una a sin tota vertical entonces
aquí tenemos una cinta vertical y de
hecho se llama así porque cuando nos
acercamos a él digamos el denominador se
hace muy pequeño verdad cuando x se hace
digamos toman valores parecidos a 3 pero
no iguales a 3
entonces el denominador se hace muy
pequeño ya sea que sea positivo
negativo verdad y así tenemos valores
para esta función que son muy grandes
digamos positivamente grandes o que son
muy grandes pero con signo negativo es
decir si lo grafica mos se vería más o
menos algo así que crece muchísimo cerca
de este valor pero por el otro lado
podría hacerse algo así verdad que que
sea muy muy negativo o bien podría verse
al revés verdad que por el lado
izquierdo se haga muy negativo mientras
que por el lado derecho se vea muy
positivo guardada por aproximándonos a
este valor y en algunos otros casos se
puede ver como más o menos de esta forma
verdad podría ocurrir también en otros
casos muy bien entonces algunas de estas
opciones podría ser la gráfica y por eso
es que les llamamos a síntomas
verticales muy bien entonces veamos otro
ejemplo veamos otro ejemplo aquí tenemos
este ejemplo que dice tenemos aquí la
función p de x y nuevamente tenemos que
encontrar cuáles de estos valores son
cero jacinto estás verticales
o discontinuidades removibles y como
siempre trata de hacer una pausa para
resolver por tu propia cuenta el
ejercicio
entonces vamos a hacerlo como en el caso
anterior vamos primero a factorizar
entonces vemos dos números que
multiplicados nos den menos 15 y sumados
esos pueden ser cinco y menos tres
entonces tenemos x más 5 por x menos 3
verdad 5 x menos 3 es menos 15 5 menos 3
es 2 muy bien y en el denominador que
podríamos poner bueno dos números que
multiplicados nos den 25 y sumados 10
esos son x + 5 por ejemplo 5 y 5 verdad
5 x 5 es 25 y cinco más cinco es 10
entonces tenemos estos dos factores muy
bien entonces nuevamente nosotros si no
si no consideramos x igual a menos 5
verdad podríamos cancelar estas
expresiones y si nos damos cuenta esto
es bastante interesante verdad porque
aquí nuevamente tenemos este factor x
más 5 verdad entonces x igual a menos 5
sería una discontinuidad removible si
éste
factor de aquí no apareciera verdad pero
ahora que si aparece este factor en el
denominador hace que digamos que
tengamos una cinta vertical en x igual a
menos 5 vamos a vamos a reescribir esto
digamos tendremos x menos 3 sobre x más
5 entonces uno pensaría que como pudimos
cancelar los factores sería
discontinuidad removible pero como
aparece otra vez este factor en realidad
es una a sin tota vertical verdad
entonces aquí uno podría pensar bueno
también tendremos que poner la
restricción como en el caso anterior
verdad en el caso anterior tuvimos que
poner la restricción para indicar que
eran expresiones algebraica mente
equivalente sin embargo aquí en este en
este ejemplo ya está implícita la
restricción verdad porque de todos modos
x no puede ser menos 5 pues estaríamos
dividiendo entre 0 así que no hay
necesidad de poner la restricción y de
hecho ya garantizamos que es 1
así en total vertical en el caso de x 3
pues esto veremos qué es lo que anula el
numerador verdad entonces podemos ver
que la función evaluada en 3 será 0
dividido entre 35 que es 8 y esto es 0
entonces justamente x igual a 3 es un
cero de nuestra función y hemos
terminado